good afternoon I'm or Lila's Roth I'm an
associate professor of neuroscience from
the department of anatomy and cell
biology at the University of Illinois at
Chicago and we're going to talk today
about neurogenesis cognitive dysfunction
and also much disease the topics that
we're going to cover today are going to
be adult neurogenesis Alzheimer's
disease we're going to talk about the
connection between those two declining
neurogenesis how does that affect
susceptibility to Alzheimer's disease
and to cognitive dysfunction as a
function of age impairments in
neurogenesis when to those take place in
Alzheimer's disease mouse model we're
going to see that critical signaling
pathways in Alzheimer's disease such as
Chris Mullin won and soluble ATP
regulate adult neurogenesis and finally
we're going to talk about environmental
manipulation that enhance enhances
neurogenesis and brain plasticity and
attenuates Alzheimer's disease
neuropathology
neural stem cells exist in the adult
brain throughout life we can find them
in the adult mammalian brain in at least
two specific areas one in is the sub
granular layer of the dentate gyrus here
is the dentate gyrus you can see my and
this is the sub granular layer of the
dentate gyrus
you can see the my labeling here and
that's where neural progenitor cells
reside and from here they migrate a
short distance into the granule layer of
the dentate gyrus in the hippocampus
the second area that exists in mammals
is the submandibular zone neural
progenitor cells migrates in rodents
they migrate through the rostral
migratory stream and end up in the
olfactory bulb as mature neurons we will
talk about the controversy concerning
the fate of those neural progenitor
cells in a human brain it is generally
accepted that neural progenitor cells or
neural stem cells are slow proliferating
lil Hitler glorious city protein
positive cells that give rise to fast
proliferating grill to glorious city
protein GFP positive cells or neural
progenitor cells those give rise to
neuroblasts but then differentiate fully
differentiate into neurons it is pretty
well established that adult neurogenesis
does take place in the human brain
it has thought that adult neurogenesis
takes place in the hippocampus and
indeed recent evidence suggests that up
to 700 new neurons are born in the adult
human brain every day in a 70 kilo zone
we do have evidence that neural
progenitor cells and neural stem cells
to exist there think is less clear there
is high controversy about their fate
let's take a look at the rodent brain as
we as we mentioned those neural
progenitor cells migrate from the 70
killer zone through the rostral
migratory stream and end up in the
olfactory bulb they're thought to
migrate in Chains of neuroblasts type
ESO sites and sheep migrating cells in
the human brain
a similar process has been described in
the fetus and within that change of
migrating neuroblasts to take place in
the in the fetal brain however in the
adult brain whether those change to take
place or not is controversial some
studies some recent studies suggest that
there are no change in what we do see
our individual or pairs of migrating
neuroblasts that at some point their
fate is not clear we do know that they
probably do not reach still factorable
and as I said what what is their fate or
what is their functional significance is
yet to be unraveled this table
summarizes the different neural
progenitor cells and populations that
exist and describes in more detail the
controversy concerning the fate of those
neural progenitor cells in the adult
human brain in the mouse and in the
monkey and in the fetal shimon as we
discussed we see very similar
observations concerning the fate of
neural progenitor cells they end up
factor about whether they do end up as
neural progenitor cells in the as mature
neurons in the adult human is yet to be
determined
current evidence suggests that they may
not reach the olfactory bulb as mature
neurons when we look at the rodent brain
we can see that in the sub granular
layer of the dentate gyrus reside type
one neural stem cells that give rise to
type two neural progenitor cells there
are two subtypes two subpopulations type
2a and two type 2b and those give rise
to type three
the neuroblast that mature into neurons
granular neurons in the granule layer of
the dentate gyrus during their
maturation they express different
transcription factors and other factors
that are specific to the timeframe and
image of their differentiation in this a
particular zone you have type 2 neural
stem cells that give rise to transit
amplifying types these cells that give
rise to type a migrating neuroblasts but
then differentiate into granule cells or
very familiar or Factory neurons so what
are neural stem cells and what is unique
about them well first of all they are
self renewing cells they have the
capability to generate exact copies of
themselves they have the ability to
undergo continuous cellular
proliferation they can generate a large
number of cellular progeny and they have
the ability to give rise to a liquid
undersides neurons and astrocytes so to
the three major cellular types in the
brain therefore if we know how to
modulate those neural progenitor cells
there is a potential ability to enhance
or support brain repair those neural
progenitor cells have the ability to
respond they respond to injury and
disease in different ways and today
we're going to talk about their
interaction with Alzheimer's disease
including the contest of in the contents
of Alzheimer's disease the dentate gyrus
is the main entry point into the
hippocampal circuitry and this is very
important when we consider the
functional significance of neural
progenitor cells we know that neural
journey
your cells that differentiate and arrive
in the granular layer of the dentate
gyrus get input from the adrenal cortex
from the intro on internal cortex
information is transmitted to the
granulosa seller after them take gyrus
and from there information is conveyed
to the CSV that conveys information to
the ca1 and from there to the cibecue
loom in back to the internal cortex
thus the dentate gyrus is very central
in terms of hippocampal structure and
function and therefore those neural
progenitor cells are very well situated
to play a role in learning and memory
and people campus dependent learning in
memory the significance of neural
progenitor cells and of adult
neurogenesis is as as we mentioned this
is a source of new neurons and glia if
we know how to modulate those neural
progenitor cells and potentially enhance
a specific lineage we are able to use
those neural progenitor cells for
replacement of their neurons or exercise
or the undersides there's increasing
evidence that those will continue to our
cells play an important role in people
campus dependent learning and memory
some evidence of their rolling or
faction dependent learning in memory
they also increase regional plasticity
they secrete neurotrophic factors they
communicate with mature circuits they
play a role in formation of new memories
trace memories specialized storage and
retrieval of subtypes of memory in
addition there's substantial evidence
that neural progenitor cells respond and
play a role an adaptation to novel
environment and new experiences and
we're going to talk about it in detail
during this lecture
in addition to that there is evidence
that altered neurogenesis is implicated
in mental depression impaired cognitive
function in different learning and
memory impairments and as we mentioned
reaction to brain damage and
neuropathology so what is the connection
between neurogenesis adult neurogenesis
and Alzheimer's disease let's talk about
Alzheimer's disease Alzheimer's disease
is a progressive neurodegenerative
disease that is characterized by memory
loss and cognitive deterioration the we
estimate that as many as 5 million
Americans are living with Alzheimer's
disease it's one of the leading causes
of death in the United States
it's a fatal disease and it's the most
common form of dementia there are other
forms of dementia vascular dementia for
example another common type of dementia
is caused by reduced blood flow to parts
of the brain there's mixed mention
Alzheimer's and vascular dementia in
dementia and in Alzheimer's disease loss
of memory difficulty learning new
information cognitive and behavioral
problems may arise all those problems
are severe enough to affect work in our
ability to live normal life to go to
work to to interact with our surrounding
with our friends or social life and so
forth unfortunately there is no cure for
Alzheimer's disease interesting
interestingly age is the greatest risk
factor for Alzheimer's disease
information that we have currently is
that one in ten individuals over 65 and
nearly half of those over 85 are
affected with Alzheimer's disease
indeed they inherited forms that we're
going to talk about in a few minutes are
we're the best majority of Alzheimer's
patients ninety-five percent of the
Alzheimer's cases are late onset form of
the disease many Americans said that
their family member they had a family
member with Alzheimer's disease we all
know someone that has the disease it's a
very common disease unfortunately as and
unfortunately as as we age the number of
Alzheimer's disease cases increases half
of all nursing house nursing home
residents have Alzheimer's disease or
related disorders a person with
Alzheimer's disease will leave an
average of eight years and as many as
twenty years or more
from the onset of symptoms so this is
not an acute disease but it's a chronic
disease it's a progressive disease and
people that have the disease that are
affected with the disease will have to
handle the the effects horrible effect
of this disease probably between eight
to twenty years from the time of the
diagnosis people with Alzheimer's
disease survive about half as long as
those with similar age without dementia
so certainly there is an effect of the
disease under not only on the quality of
life but also on the length again an
estimation of forty five to five million
Americans have Alzheimer's disease and
we estimate that by 2050 there's we're
going to triple this number
unfortunately the cost of Alzheimer's
disease to the American Society is
enormous the estimation is 6 to 1
billion a year and it might increase as
we have more Alzheimer's disease cases
and this information is taken from the
information of the Alzheimer's
Association
so also MERS disease is a progressive
neurodegenerative disease that is
characterized by numerous there's
cognitive deficits eventually
development of dementia
there's altered behavior occasionally
people suffer from paranoid delusions
and loss of social appropriateness there
are groups of neurons that are highly
vulnerable in Alzheimer's disease and
are those to be affected first in the
hippocampal formation in the internal
cortex and to remind you that
hippocampal formation and the internal
cortex are part of the circuit in which
neurogenesis adult neurogenesis takes
place in the hippocampus the hallmarks
of the disease are amyloid deposition
you see my here Emily the positions are
in green here these are aggregates of
beta amyloid four kilo Dalton peptide
we're going to talk about the metabolism
of amyloid and nor feeble rectangles
that are intracellular aggregates of
hyper phosphorylated tau in neurons you
see my arrow as we mentioned before the
familial early onset form of Alzheimer's
disease is caused by mutations in
amyloid precursor protein mutation in
personal and Ron a mutation in personal
and - but again those familial forms are
very rare the best majority of
Alzheimer's cases are the late onset
sporadic form of the disease the risk is
mostly age as well as equally four
allele the progression of the pathology
in terms of normal progression there are
neurofibrillary tangles the internal
cortex with minimal neuronal loss early
earlier stages of the disease later on
amyloid plaques and neurofibrillary
tangles throughout the cortex and the
temporal formation
massive neuronal loss in these areas
neuronal loss in layer two of the
entorhinal cortex and the c1 region
increased amyloid opposition and
neurofibrillary tangles so now that we
are familiar with the disease let's talk
about the significance of neurogenesis
adult neurogenesis when it comes to
Alzheimer's disease the first we
mentioned that aging is the greatest
risk factor for sporadic Alzheimer's
disease there is a decline in extent of
proliferation and neural differentiation
and survival of neural progenitor cells
in the aging brain this is a
quantification of neurogenesis as a
function of age in the mouse brain
let's do let's take a look at this slide
we see that the number of Brahma deoxy
already in positive brdu is a cell cycle
marker that incorporates in the DNA of
proliferating cells therefore brdu
positive cells and we repeat this term
many times during this lecture we are
doing positive cells are proliferating
cells those proliferating cells in the
subcommittee career zone this is a
quantification of the seven ticular Zone
in the adult Mouse and you can see here
that in a two-month-old there is a great
extent of proliferation which declines
dramatically by 7 to 9 months of age
suggesting that during early young
adults lose a significant extent of
proliferation of world janitor cells
when we look at the number of
neuroblasts be sure we are do you
positive cells double corden positive
cells double protein is a murderer nor
blessin in mature neurons we can see the
same phenomenon we can see that in the
two months in young in the brain of two
months old animals there is a
significant extent of Northwest's
that then declines dramatically reduced
by seven to nine months a
and further reduced by 21 so there is a
dramatic decline of neuroblasts that
give rise to neural progenitor cells -
I'm sorry - mature neurons as a function
of age you can see the line that I live
in when we look at immature neurons we
see the same phenomenon interestingly
enough when we look at we also glory
acidic protein positive and nested
positive these are neural stem cells
oh yes and not proliferating population
of neural stem cells we see that this
operation does not decline as a function
of age suggesting that the reduction in
neurogenesis is not due to a decline in
the pool of neural stem cells again it
looks like the reduction in neurogenesis
has to do with extent of proliferation
and or potentially survival of those
neural progenitor cells that then give
rise to less neurons that incorporate in
the olfactory bulb when we look at the
sub granular layer we see the same
phenomenon we see that at 2 months of
age we had a great extent of
proliferation in the sub granular layer
of the dentate gyrus you can see here
cells neural progenitor cells my arrow
will progenitor cells that are labeled
here in green and this is brdu staining
and you can see the red staining which
is double cortland and you can see that
at 2 months of age we have many
proliferating cells in the sub granular
layer and this number dramatically
declines by early adulthood 7 to 9
months of age in the mouse when we look
at neuroblasts again there is a an age
dependent decline in the NAM
of neural progenitor cells in the sub
granular layer of the pajamas of the
mouse immature neurons again a dramatic
decline as a function of age of the
number of immature neurons that exist in
the sub granular layer of the dentate
gyrus and interestingly enough when we
look at the population of neural stem
cells right here on the on the right we
see that there is no decline in the
number of neural stem cells the
quiescent neural stem cells GFE p+
nesting positive cells as a function of
age in the mouse brain suggesting again
that the decline in neurogenesis as a
function of age is probably not due to a
decline in the number of neural stem
cells so we said that aging is the
greatest risk factor for Alzheimer's
disease and indeed decline in extent of
proliferation and as a result of the
number of mature neurons that
incorporate in the hippocampus and/or in
the olfactory bulb declines with age
which might might make those regions
more vulnerable less prepared less
resilient to to aging and to aging link
disease in addition functionally this
may affect the ability of the
hippocampus and the olfactory ball to to
function so progressive loss of people
campus dependent learning in memory is
one of the characteristics of
Alzheimer's disease and impaired
neurogenesis may enhance or exacerbate
hippocampal dysfunction modulation of
neurogenesis may attenuate learning and
memory deficits if we know how to how to
do that of course
likewise progressive and massive loss of
neurons in the hippocampus and in the
cortex and impaired neurogenesis may
result in addition in addition
to the fact that we have less neurons
impaired neurogenesis may also result in
lack of nor trophic factors which might
make those neurons in the hippocampal
circuitry and in the cortical circuitry
more vulnerable less neurotropic factors
less neurons that incorporate and in
respond to critical cues and cortical
signals increase normal gulnur ability
in both hippocampal formation importance
likewise affection dependent learning in
memory and here were referring mainly to
the rodent as Imperial faction is one of
the although impaired infection is one
of the earliest markers of possible
Alzheimer's disease currently we're not
we're not sure about the role of adult
neurogenesis in human olfaction deficits
in olfactory sensitivity we know that
order discrimination the ability to
discriminate between different orders is
one of the earliest signs of cognitive
impairments in both Alzheimer's disease
and in Parkinson's disease and if adult
neurogenesis does play a role in
olfaction it might affect this process
as well and lastly molecular mechanism
and we're going to talk about how
signaling pathways that are linked to
familial Alzheimer's disease play a role
in adult neurogenesis this is a summary
of many signaling pathways and we have
no time to talk about all of them but
we're going to choose two of them and
we're going to talk about their role in
adult neurogenesis but for those of you
who will be interested this table
summarizes the numerous signaling
pathways that are that link Alzheimer's
disease and neurogenesis this includes
the different secretaries that play a
role in metabolism of amyloid precursor
protein in Alzheimer's disease
in many neurogenic signaling pathways
such as air before EGF receptor and
others that are linked to both
Alzheimer's disease and neurogenesis as
we mentioned at the beginning of the
talk familial Alzheimer's disease is
caused by mutations in amyloid precursor
protein crystalline one in prisoner into
let's take a look at what we know so far
about the metabolism of those molecules
in blue here is amyloid precursor
protein this is a type 1 glycoprotein it
spans the membrane one time this is a
110 to 130 kilo Dalton glycoprotein in
red here is the beta amyloid that a
better peptide that is a foreign key
little compact item there are at least
two metabolic pathways by which amyloid
precursor protein or a PP is cleaved one
is the Nanami later Jenica pathway by
alpha secretase and in that pathway our
facilities cliffs in the a bed of region
and thus a better is not formed it's not
generated the second pathway is the
analog of genic pathway which a PP is
cleaved by better Socrates or base one
in neurons in the N terminus of a beta
and gamma secretase personally in gamma
secretase cleaves the C terminus of a
better boxing terminus and a beta is
released in Alzheimer's disease the
level of stickiness and the length of a
beta changes in the ratio of the
different peptides that are generated
following those two cleavages changes
and as a result of that there is a
deposition of those amyloid peptides in
the form of amyloid deposition
personnel and one in person two are
highly homologous proteins that are
thought to be the catalytic or of gamma
secretase so they play a major role in
the cleavage of ATP to yield a better
now in order to understand if
neurogenesis is indeed altered
non-swimmers disease the first thing we
have done was to look at extent of
neurogenesis in transgenic mice that
Express mutant forms of amyloid
precursor protein and prison all in one
so indeed we're talking about animals
that express a PP Swedish mutation of a
P P and the delta T 9 mutation of
personal in one and when we look at the
extent of neurogenesis when we look at
the number of proliferating cells in the
sub granular layer in subventricular
zone of this mice and here you can see
the seventh occurs on these are wild
type mice you can see here the seventy
career zone when we look at the brains
of non transgenic mice you can see that
the extent of proliferation in the
double transgenic in the APB's swedish
ps1 delta e 9 is reduced compared to
wild-type mice now it is important to
mention that this are very young animals
these are animals at 2 months of age
suggesting that impairment in
neurogenesis take place very early in
the disease earlier than the onset of
amyloid opposition earlier than
cognitive deficits in this noise very
early that suggests to us that
impairments in neurogenesis might play a
role in the development of the disease
let's take a look at the number of
neural blasts in this mice and we can
see here that there is a reduction in
the number of neural blasts in the
brains of double
genik mice compared to wild-type mice so
indeed both the reduction in extent of
proliferation and in early normal
maturation in the sub particular zone of
this noise let's take a look at the sub
granular layer and we can see that in
mutant mice there is a reduction in the
extent of proliferation and in the
extent of normal differentiation in a
sub granular layer of the dentate gyrus
of transgenic mice that Express mutant
forms of familial Alzheimer's disease
now the question is what is what is the
mechanism and whether signaling pathways
that are linked to familial Alzheimer's
disease play a role in neurogenesis
interestingly mice with targeted
disruption in the personnel and locus
this mutation is lethal and the mice are
not born they die at 17 or 18 and
therefore this setting this mutation
does not allow us to look at adult
neurogenesis we do know from this mice
that their ventricular zone is
substantially scener compared to the
normal Mouse and we know that in the in
the mutant brain after embryonic a 14.5
the ventricular zone looks substantially
thinner and that indicates a drastic
reduction in the number of neural
progenitor cells in addition to that we
know that expression of notch 1 which is
an extremely important neurogenic
signaling and it's lagging is
dramatically reduced in the PSone mice
therefore we asked whether prisoner and
one plays a role in adult neurogenesis
as well in order to answer this question
we generated Lenti viral vectors that
Express
RNA interference to knock down personal
in one specifically in neural progenitor
cells we know today that the gamma
secretase in Alzheimer's disease both we
suspect that both in the sporadic and in
familial Alzheimer's disease there is
loss of activity of gamma secretase and
indeed if you look here in those in the
Western blot that is on the right here
you can see that compared to the control
the level of person million following
the use of Lenti viral vectors the
expression of personal in 1 is reduced
you can see here a quantification of
this of this Western blot and you can
see that person and one expression is
indeed reduced following infection of
neural progenitor cells with 20 viral
vectors expressing Si RNA that targets
personal in one so we use this went
viral vectors that express a serenade to
knock down prisoner 1 you can see here
that neural progenitor cells in the sub
granular layer of the dentate gyrus
expressed green fluorescent protein that
is expressed along with sa RNA to knock
down prison room 1 and you can see here
that injections to ataxic injection of
Lenti viral vectors into the soprano a
layer of the dentate gyrus indeed labels
neural progenitor cells exclusively in
the sub granular layer other than page
iris you can see this same green layer
here of neural progenitor cells that are
infected with the lentivirus
specifically in the sub granular layer
of the hippocampus and this on the left
here you can see Western blot analysis
that show that there is a reduction in
the level of expression of prisoners one
in hippocampi of mice that were injected
with Lenti viral vectors expressing if
they are innate to knock down prisoner
in one
interestingly when we knock down
personnel in one in neural progenitor
cells we see a reduction in the
proliferation of neural progenitor cells
and we also see a differentiation cell
differentiation we see differentiation
into mature neurons and we see an
increase this one this graph also shows
increased differentiation increased
normal differentiation in neural
progenitor cells that are infected with
Lenti viral vectors expressing as a RNA
to knock down crystalline one to
understand again to understand what is
the what is the mechanism by which
personally one alters neural progenitor
cell biology reduces their extent of
proliferation and enhances their
differentiation we looked at these
processes in vitro and indeed we
observed that there is an increased
following down regulation of person and
one in neural progenitor cells we
observe that there is up regulation of
speech Ibelin which means that there's
reduction in neural progenitor cell
proliferation and enhanced
differentiation we also see enhanced
expression of s100 better suggesting an
increase in differentiation into mature
sites and potentially into
oligodendrocyte egg lineage cells that
express PDGF receptor suggesting that
when we down regulate crystalline one a
situation that might resemble the loss
of gamma-secretase activity and crystal
one expression in sporadic Alzheimer's
disease and in formula Alzheimer's
disease the way that that affects
neurogenesis in the adult brain is by
down-regulating
the extent of proliferation of neural
progenitor cells and enhancing neuronal
differentiation
the question question is of course
whether those neurons are functional if
this early differentiation is indeed a
good differentiation is indeed a
functional differentiation or whether
those neurons are not as functional as
we would hope in this experiment you can
see the effect of Si RMA on neural
progenitor cell cultures in vitro you
can see here that neural progenitor
cells in vitro formed those circular
neurospheres you can see my my labeling
here these are neurospheres of neural
progenitor cells that upon infection
with si RNA to knock down personnel in
1000 or alpha janitor cells
differentiate and are no longer in the
form of neurospheres so obviously there
is a very clear phenotype here when we
down regulate personal in 1 in neural
progenitor cells they their
proliferation is reduced and they
differentiate immediately into neurons
and glia we can see that quantification
on the on the bottom left here this is
the number of neurospheres is produced
and the number of differentiated cells
is increased following down regulation
of person 1 so what are the signaling
pathways that regulate personnel and
want effect on our neural progenitor
cells for that we performed real-time
PCR and we observed alterations in beta
catenin we observed reduction in EGF
receptor and in an increase in the notch
ligand l1 and we suspect that those
those candidates may play a role in
personally one mediated or regulated
neurogenesis in the adult brain
so to summarize this art personal in one
that is thought to be the catalytic core
of gamma secretase that cleaves amyloid
precursor protein to yield a better is a
major regulator of adult neurogenesis
down regulation of crystalline one
reduces neural progenitor cell
proliferation and enhances royal
differentiation and we think that this
is through not medica Tinian and EGF
signaling pathways so that suggests that
indeed dysfunction of personal anyone in
gamma secretase as a function of age or
as a function of mutation expression
directly compromises neurogenesis in the
hippocampus and in the seventy killer
zone leading subsequently to reduce
number of functional new neurons in the
hippocampus the second signaling I will
mention briefly is soluble a PP this is
a picture here on the right that is
taken from a fascinating paper that was
published in Nature in 1999 that
suggests that soluble a P P is a
neurotrophic factor that proliferation
factor and there's there's several
publications well during the years that
suggested that soluble a PP regulates
regulates proliferation of several cell
types such as fiberglass parasite
proliferation and so forth
and to remind you soluble a PP comes in
two forms soluble a PP alpha that is the
cleavage product of the non Emilio genic
pathway and soluble a PP beta that is
the product of the amyloid of genic
pathway provide better secretase and
gown secretaries when we looked at the
effect of soluble a PP alpha what we
observed was that when we tricked neural
progenitor cells with alpha second
inhibitor we observe a reduction in
neural progenitor cell proliferation as
indicated by the diameter of the average
diameter of neurospheres in vitro
treatment with better secretase inhibit
or indeed yell yields the same
observation there is a reduction in
proliferation of neural progenitor cell
proliferation and treatment with both is
not additive but we see the same effect
when we supplement the culture with
soluble AP P alpha recombinant soluble
AP P alpha we are able to recover some
of the proliferation effect
interestingly enough when we supplement
with soluble a P P better we are not
able to rescue the effect on
proliferation this is expressed in both
for the younger of the neurospheres and
in the total number of neural progenitor
cells that is present in those neural
progenitor cells so indeed when we treat
again with alpha or beta Secretary's
inhibitors to get a dramatic reduction
in proliferation and cell able a P P
alpha is not soluble ATT better is able
to recover this proliferation injection
of soluble a P P alpha into the seven
ticular zone yields up regulation of
neural progenitor cell proliferation we
can see it right here in both the
semantic euro zone and in the subretinal
layer of the dentate gyrus interestingly
enough there is a reduction in the
number of neural stem cells in those
regions and we see the same phenomenon
in both the 70 euro zone and in several
you can see here in the sub granular
layer that there is an increase in the
number of proliferating cells following
injection of soluble a P P alpha and
increase in the number of neural
progenitor cells that proliferate in the
decrease in the number of neural stem
cells in those regions following soluble
ATP Alfred
interestingly enough there is a
reduction in the number of neural
progenitor cells for an injection of
soluble ATP better the amyloid or genic
product of ATP we see that in both a 70
color zone and in the soprano a layer of
the dentate gyrus and that suggests that
indeed soluble a P P alpha regulates
neural progenitor cell proliferation has
the neurotrophic effect and the ability
to increase neural progenitor cell
proliferation soluble ATP the effect of
soluble a PP alpha at least his
experiments suggest that soluble ATP
better does not exhibit the same the
same effect in similar concentrations
and soluble ap P alpha and it is
possible that in different
concentrations soluble a P P better has
a different effect but in those
concentrations that have been used here
soluble a P P alpha exhibits a
proliferative effect on neural
progenitor cells and neurotropic effect
while soluble ATP better that is
increased in Alzheimer's disease does
not show the same effect environmental
enrichment is a widely used experimental
model that is well known to increase
numerous aspects of brain plasticity
such as survival of newborn cells in the
dentate gyrus enhances recovery from
lesion induced memory deficits increases
the number of dendritic spines and
enhances memory function in various
learning tests this is again a very a
widely used experimental model to
enhance for in Foster City and one of
the question is if if neurogenesis in
hippocampal plasticity are affected in
Alzheimer's disease are we able to
enhance people camp elasticity and
neurogenesis in a way that would support
the Alzheimer's brain so let's let's
take a look
in a previous experiments from a while
ago we have shown that indeed when
transgenic mice that expressed expressed
mutant forms of Alzheimer's disease
again we're talking about mutant forms a
PP mutant and personal and mutant forms
when this mice experienced environmental
enrichment there is a dramatic reduction
in the extent of amyloid deposition and
you can see it here this is the
quantification mice that experience
environmental enrichment exhibits less
amyloid deposition in their brains
there's also reduction in the soluble
forms soluble a better 42 and soluble a
better I'm sorry soluble the church
insoluble a bit of 42 and formic acid
solid a better for DT I should mention
that there are other studies that had
opposite observations and suggest that
actually environmental enrichment up
regulates amyloid deposition our
observations suggest that experience of
mice in environmental enrichment down
regulates amyloid deposition insoluble
soluble level soluble forms of a better
in addition to that we found that
following environmental enrichment there
is up regulation of a better degrading
enzyme in later experiments we have
shown that indeed following experience
of this noise in environmental
enrichment there is up regulation of
proliferation of neural progenitor cells
this is in non transgenic mice and you
can see that in transgenic mice in the
Alzheimer's disease transgenic mice we
see the same phenomenon following
environmental enrichment this mice
exhibit greater extent of proliferation
of neural progenitor cells in the sub
granule aware of the dentate gyrus
moreover those wild-type mice following
environmental enrichment exhibit an
increased number of neuroblasts and
transgenic mice
exhibit a very similar phenomenon in
Chris in the number of neural progenitor
cells and immature in the neuroblasts in
the seventy glare zone of this mice in
addition to that we see that there is a
substantial increase in the number of
new neurons in the granular layer of the
dentate gyrus of transgenic mice
following environmental enrichment we
also find an increase in the number of
newly formed astrocytes in the in the
sub granular layer of with integers
suggesting indeed that behavioral
manipulation an experience of this
transgenic mice in environmental
enrichment up regulates extent of
neurogenesis we repeatedly observed that
indeed there is a reduction in levels of
oligomeric a beta in both the
hippocampus and the cortex of this mice
suggesting that experience of transgenic
mice in environmental enrichment both up
regulates extent of plasticity and
neurogenesis and down regulates
neuropathology in the brains of this
month in addition to amyloidosis we also
see a reduction in the expression of
hyper phosphorylated tau you can look
here at the Western blot that shows that
in the hippocampus of mice that were
maintaining standard housing conditions
there is more hyper phosphorylated tau
and compared to the brains or the
hippocampus of mice that experience
environmental enrichment in addition to
those exciting results we also see an
increase in expression of kinesin light
chain in kinesin heavy chain the
components of the anterograde motor
anterograde motor neurons suggesting
that potentially experience of mice in
environmental enrichment enhances or up
graduates external transport processes
to understand the molecular mechanism of
environmental enrichment we
first of all looked at potential
candidates that can that participate in
both down-regulation of tile
phosphorylation and up regulation of
Keynesian components and we know that
there are several kinase activities that
play a role in both child
phosphorylation and in Keynesian
acceleration and indeed one of them is
GSK three better when we look at GSK
three better we see that expression of
jiske three better is pretty similar in
both in the brains in the hippocampus of
both non-transgenic and transgenic mice
however as a function of age there is a
an increase in expression of GSK three
better we it is important that we note
that we're talking about here about
fossil GSK to be better
the inactive form of GSK to be better a
so when we see a regular down-regulation
here it means that there's up regulation
of GST three better activity and indeed
we see here that in non transgenic mice
there is down regulation GSK could be
better the active form of cheesecakes we
better while this reduction is not
observed in the brains of double
transgenic mice following environmental
enrichment suggesting indeed that GSK 3
beta is down regulated following
environmental enrichment in the brains
of wild-type mice but not in the brains
of transgenic mice expressing familial
Alzheimer's forms the activator or the I
should see the down regulator of GSK 3
better akt exhibits a very similar
phenomena we see that as a function of
age there is a decrease in the level of
possible in KT while in non transgenic
mice following environmental enrichment
we see that there is a regulation of
pathway katie's suggesting that this may
impose even further down regulation of
GSK to be better however in the double
transgenic mice we see that there is no
change in the weather
for nicotine suggesting that those
pathways are not affected for some
reason in transgenic mice expressing a
pee-pee and personally one compared to
wild-type mice in which both Busboys akt
NGS case we better are being modulated
by environmental enrichment when we look
at production of neurotropic factors
with the we see that there is a increase
a significant increase in production of
brain derived neurotrophic factor BDNF
and a significant increase in beginner
receptor in both in the brains of
immutable campus of both transgenic and
wild-type mice for one environmental
enrichment we see that by both green
point PCR and by I Eliza by on the
protein level they say that there is an
increase in the level of BDNF we also
see that there is an increase in the
level of PPA that plays role in the
metabolism of BDNF - to generate mature
in DNF when we look at other
neurotrophic factors we see that there
is also an increase in the level of your
growth factor and interestingly enough
we see that there is a regulation of
nurturing 3 in the brains of non
transgenic mice but not in the brains of
transgenic mice only environmental
enrichment the opposite observation is
concerning igf-1 here we see no increase
in the brains of wild-type mice but we
see an increase in the brains of double
transgenic for environmental enrichment
interestingly enough when we look at
downstream signals at grabbed in
relation to
signaling that are downstream of GSK 3
in neuro traffic signaling pathways and
are
relate significantly related to learning
and memory we see that there is increase
in crime expression in both non
genik and transgenic mice following
environmental enrichment we also see
that there is an increase in NF energy
every stick tourists in both wildlife
and non transgenic mice however when we
look at cred phosphorylation that is a
process that is crucial for formation of
long term memories and for learning we
see that when it comes to the wild-type
brain we see that indeed following
environmental enrichment there is an
increase in the level of fossil crab in
the brains of wild-type mice however
when we look at the brain of transgenic
mice we see that there is no increase in
the level of fossil crab along
environmental enrichment and that is
very interesting the question is whether
crab does play a role in environmental
enrichment mediated plasticity and
learning in memory and that is yet to be
determined
so to summarize this art we unraveled
some of the signaling pathways that play
a role in environmental enrichment
induced plasticity in wild-type and
Alzheimer's mice and we know that there
is upregulation of neurotrophic factors
that then downstream activate the akt
signaling pathway that then in activates
GS k3 that might affect the level of tau
phosphorylation in the transgenic mice
in the Alzheimer's mice this part seems
not to take place a KT and GSK 3 better
are not modulated by environmental
enrichment in the hippocampus of
transgenic mice and that may suggest
that their other pathways mediate the
process of tau of reduction of kalfus
correlation in the brains of transgenic
mice
interestingly enough we also do not see
up regulation of possible crab
expression in transgenic mice suggesting
that neither crab does not play a major
role in environmental enrichment induce
plasticity or that crab pathway is
impaired in Alzheimer's disease and is
not recovered or not rescued by
environmental enrichment mechanisms to
summarize our lecture today we talked
about impairments in neurogenesis and
how they take place in both the aging
brain and very early in the brains of
young mice that expressed mutant forms
of Alzheimer's disease
we learned that critical signaling that
are linked to Alzheimer's disease such
as personal in one insoluble ABP
regulate neurogenesis we learned that
this function of crystalline one down
regulation of personal in one impairs
neurogenesis and potentially also
learning in memory and it would be
interesting to determine whether those
neurons that Express or exhibit reduced
level of crystalline one our functional
neurons to the extent that they can
actually mediate learning in memory
properly we have seen that modulation of
decline neurogenesis during aging may
attenuate cognitive deficits and
susceptibility to Alzheimer's disease
and that modulation of environmental
factors such as we've seen in
environmental and which following
environmental enrichment may a critical
role in the formation of Alzheimer's
disease in potentially if we know how to
translate environmental enrichment we
may attenuate the disease and this
cartoon is meant to show that when
neurogenesis is upregulated there's more
neurotrophic factors and the hippocampus
is fully functional
in elasticity is in its best well.when
neurotrophic factors are down and
neurogenesis is impaired that would
affect the morphology and the function
of the hippocampus leading to
vulnerability to Alzheimer's disease and
dysfunction of learning and memory
pathways and that suggests that there is
a a direct relation between neurogenesis
Alzheimer's disease and aging when
neurogenesis declines during aging that
makes the brain Honorable 12 Summers
disease thank you
yes there is a question that says the
Djinn and all and colleagues suggest
that there is an increase of
neurogenesis and Alzheimer's disease
could you explain it more absolutely
as we mentioned that soluble a P P
enhances proliferation of neural
progenitor cells I believe that the in
the ATP mice in contrast to the prison
alone expressing mice this effect might
be the effect of soluble a P P alpha and
beta that plane concert to remodulate or
Genesis so in this case the effect of
soluble a P P alpha in soluble a P P
beta is very dominant in these animals
and I believe this is probably the
effect of of this components compared to
mice that Express personnel in one or
two mutations and or ATP